my agent he watched me really just
um be a shell of myself he said jeremy
this might be your last game in the nba
dude your back is against the wall and
if you're getting knocked out
do it does it again
[Applause]
[Music]
basically what happened was we played in
boston we got back around you know
whatever like 1am 2am that i was on
landry fields couch um because my
brother
and sister-in-law had friends in town so
they were crashing on the couch where i
normally crash and so by the time we get
to landry's apartment he's like this is
my couch i told you it was small and i
was like oh my goodness this is smaller
than i thought and
i had my head hanging off one end legs
hanging off the other i was curled up
you know in a fetal position i still
couldn't even fit on the couch
so i wake up the next morning
terrible night's rest so immediately go
to skytown grab a fresh set of clothes
and i stopped by papaya dog and then i
went to msg and that was just my day and
it was just like this feeling of like is
this the end
and you know i remember my agent calling
me and he was basically saying like look
this is probably your last game in the
nba
if you don't if they even give you an
opportunity on the floor he said uh and
he had been walking through me with me
through all my
you know my overthinking my insecurities
my anxiety and he watched me really just
be a shell of myself my whole rookie
year and he told me he said he said
jeremy this might be your last game in
the nba
if it is you
gotta go out playing jeremy lin
basketball and that really stuck with me
and i was like
i gotta swing for defenses tonight and
just go for it
jeremy lin and you're a pretty big
ovation growing up
new york basketball was not easy to like
basketball
in new york city is its lifeblood and
the knicks have been
awful
and he brought energy to the knicks like
i've never seen before and haven't seen
since i started i was just i was loose
and i just feel like that was really
supernatural because i struggled
a lot with pregame anxiety but like for
whatever reason that day when i got
subbed in i was just great
drives and fashions nice play from three
for 14. normally if i had four points in
the game i'd be like that's a good game
so i was like dude that's a great
like i'm really happy with this hat but
then in the second half like i don't
even know what happened it was just a
blur it just flowed and i just got in
the zone
a magical night for jeremy lin he's the
hero from harvard on the game of his
life
immediately i went to eat with my
parents
my phone was just going insane like i
had hundreds of messages
and then i got home you know with my
brother and sister-in-law and i was
about to crash in their couch they were
like dude what happened i was like i
don't know and we were just like we're
all in shock and then i pull up espn and
i'm on i'm on the front page and so now
we're all geeking out and i'm taking
photos and screenshots coolest thing
about it was i got to celebrate it with
the people that i was closest to who
have been with me who had told me not to
quit when i was ready to quit gordon was
absolutely electric every game felt like
game seven
nick fans are still excited but not as
exciting as it was during you know lynn
saturday i became a knicks fan at the
time um i think he gave us a lift at a
time when we needed it
insanity brought a ton of energy and a
little bit of winning which we didn't
have at that time
[Music]
i hated it for years
like i just
my whole life i've always wanted to just
be like jeremy like almost felt like
phenomenon which i was never really down
with but
i realized like later
i came to really accept it and embrace
it now because
to other people that was that that was
like such a moment of inspiration you
know he could have been a king in new
york
then he just you know it's get this hope
this
this energy this love that you know this
one guy just brought to the city and
just like that it was gone
i was always the underdog i was always
surprising people it was always like oh
he's better than we thought so i'd never
been in a position where i was like i
had any expectations
now it's like
i almost became like public enemy number
one um
to the new york fan base
and i think what was really
disheartening about it was that the the
claims that were in the things that were
people were saying about me weren't true
and i think that's what really hurt me
and that's when i kind of realized like
perception is reality and
and i actually tried to you know go back
and ask the rockets i wanted the rockets
to give me less so that new york could
match i was trying to do everything
behind the scenes so i could stay in new
york um and a lot of what had happened
and the aftermath and the fallout i
actually still to this day am not aware
of why it happened how it happened or
whatever but that fallout
was
one of the tougher things that i've had
to experience and and it really bothered
me deeply
and i felt extremely misunderstood
you know there was just this energy
that's hard to really vocalize
you know unless you're from a city or a
town that has a sports team that they
just love to see the garden actually
light up change my perspective on
basketball a little bit this is next
matter was it good or bad no matter what
they fit with nick fans i always
appreciate that
as a new yorker i'm glad that we had
jeremy lin in our city so jerry man we
loved you we still love you and i still
have
all the wristbands the insanity
wristbands i have about 30 of them
sitting in a box in my house so we
always are looking like
that's cool
i'll always have love for new york every
time i go back it's just it's love ten
years even even nine ten years later
doesn't matter if i'm back there it's
like dude
let me tell you where i was when this
happened dude let me tell you how this
impacted me we were thinking about
what's the best way to honor
the 10-year anniversary of insanity
and we felt like the best way to honor
is to give back
because the city and the fans gave us so
much and so
we're starting a fundraising campaign to
be able to
give the profits and the proceeds to
organizations in new york to be able to
try to help you're looking at setbacks
and education and resources
opportunities you're looking at mental
health issues for youth you're looking
at a lot of
delay you know and restriction of access
to sports and extracurriculars like
we're in this together we're a community
we're a humanity and that's what's so
special about the story it could have
happened in any city but the fact that
it happened in new york
at msg
there's no better city for it to happen
in the world